hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schnell wir können in erfüllung gehen
denn heute machen wir endlich den
apfelstrudel aus fantastische tier wesen
und wo sie zu finden sind diese film
spielt im harry potter universum bagdad
akteure
es geht in dem film um den money zoologe
news gemander der 1926 mit einem schiff
nach new york kommen ihr harry potter
nutzer draußen könnt mir doch bestimmt
verraten warum er ein schiff als
fortbewegungsmittel benutzt und nicht
irgend etwas schnellere aus england nach
new york mit dem schiff zu fahrenden
mindestens zwei wochen warum benutzt
nicht irgend etwas magisches damit es
schneller und dann passieren ganz viele
coole magische sachen und ich will
eigentlich auch noch nicht so viel vom
film verraten also wenn ihr den film
noch nicht gesehen habt dann holt es
jetzt bitte nach fantastische tier wesen
und wo dieser film zu finden ist
natürlich auch skydiver nämlich so liebt
und hat mir ein neues angebot gezeigt
was ich euch jetzt sehr gerne
weitergeben möchte denn bis juni könnt
ihr für neun euro 99 das sind zwei
monate zwei monate für 999 dass geist
cinema ticket ausprobieren und da findet
ihr nicht nur fantastische wesen sondern
auch neue filme wie congstar island ich
einfach unverbesserlich 3 der neue lego
batman film oder fluch der karibik 5 ja
es gibt schon fünf teile ich finds hier
wieder super dass man es monatlich
kündigen kann dass man es teilweise in
der originalsprache anschauen kann und
dass es keine werbung gibt armen also
wenn ihr lust habt filme anzuschauen
kurz nachdem sie im kino waren an jack
mal den ersten link in der infobox aus
da kommt ihr zum angebot 990 für zwei
monate
ich finde das ist ein google
handbewegung stewardess
wenn sie lust haben einen kinofilm
anzuschauen klicken sie bitte unten den
ersten link wir wünschen ihnen noch
einen weitere schöne anschauung dieses
video werbung ende machen wir weiter mit
unserem apfelstrudel
der dating wollte sehen wie ich den
apfel in eine banane verwandle abschluss
ba nanos magic maniche wird so gern
zaubern können du musst es ist
warum habe ich denn so lustige haare nun
ja das liegt daran dass der apfelstrudel
von queen ii gemacht wird und queenie
hat genau so eine süße frisur und kredit
redet ganz lieb und sie hat eine ganz
zarte stimme alles das was ich nicht
habe denn ich klingle manchmal ein
bisschen härter als ich eigentlich bin
ich kann auch sehr tief sprechen wenn
ich möchte diese apfelstrudel wird zwar
mit magie hergestellt aber man kann
eigentlich jeden einzelnen schritt gut
beobachten erst sieht man die äpfel in
der luft schweben wie sie geschält
werden und dann fliegen sie zusammen mit
zucker und rosinen in einen blätterteig
hinein dann gibt es da noch so drei
fläche und sechs apfel rosen die mir
glaube ich am meisten sorgen machen wer
die erste frage wie ich mir gestellt
habe wie schmeckt etwas wo es jetzt
nimmt da ist kein zimmer mit
reingeflogen sie benutze zucker äpfel
und rosin kann mir das mal jemand
erklären und jetzt lasst uns versuchen
diesen apfelstrudel zu zaubern
ohne magie dafür mit unseren fingern
spirit fingers wer kennt den film noch
zuerst schälen und schneiden wir vier
äpfel pendant natürlich dürft ihr nicht
vergessen eure erfüllt zu probieren
ich habe mit absicht zwei rot und zwei
grüne genommen weil die apfelstücke in
dem film auch so grünlich und rötlich
waren unsere ab wichtige werden wir
jetzt ganz magisch in eine schüssel
bringen ohne dass was rausfällt und
jetzt kommen wie im film ein paar
rosinen bei geflogen
wie macht sie das nur
es ist und bleibt ein rätsel
und zum schluss fliegt dann auch ganz
magisch eine ganz fette prise zugaben
drauf und jetzt vergüten natürlich alles
mit eurem magischen kochen erfüllen
die abmischung lassen wir jetzt ein
bisschen stehen und in der zeit kümmern
wir uns um den blätterteig und jetzt
meine damen und herren kommen wir zum
allerbesten teil wir bauen das
blätterteig konstrukt abzocker während
klinik mit ihrem zauberstab umbildet
werden drei geschichten so übereinander
geräumt und das ist unsere erste
blätterteig sich rolf jetzt noch ein
bisschen dünner weil wir in filmen
dünner vorkommt also blätterteig nummer
eins direkt magic blätterteig nummer
zwei und blätterteig nummer drei mit
unserer rabattiert so leicht
konstruktion kann jetzt nichts schief
gehen glaubt jetzt ein bisschen
langweilig lembeck ehre so das brauchen
wir noch das wird ein richtig blättrigen
blätter teilweise drei schichten
blätterteig greg craig oder macht man
strudel so ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt
noch nie einen apfelstrudel gemacht
jetzt kommt nun zu weit auch so lang wie
momentan und jetzt kommt der dritte
jetzt haben wir drei schichten
blätterteig übereinander gelegt wie im
film
also ich gehe ja nur nach dem film
pilgern müssen ihn jetzt befüllen und
dann noch diese flechten zöpfe drumrum
machen aber das kriegen wir für unsere
füllung dem jetzt unsere äpfel rosinen
mischung und legen sie einfach mal drauf
das sieht doch gar nicht mal so schlecht
aus wir sind flüssigkeit noch drüber und
falls ich schon mal so viel gemacht habt
ist das jetzt nicht so schwer ihr
wickelt das jetzt wie von zauberhand
drüber ich hätte man das in die mitte
guck mal wie ich fahren kann okay ist
doch gar nicht so schlecht
dies geschieht macht jetzt auch
apfelstrudel so schienen also das ist
schon mal ein bisschen liebesfilm in der
szene sieht man auch ganz genau dass die
seiten oft sind also lassen wir unsere
seiten auch auf ich hoffe das ist eine
gute idee und jetzt werde ich versuchen
diese fläche zu machen wir brauchen drei
vielleicht zapfe x 33 x 3 und 9
erst mal in 3 43
was würdet ihr eine richtige
bastelstunde und die jetzt noch mal in
drei kinder wer kein schlechtes kann
sollte jetzt aufpassen und jetzt
vielleicht stören bieten die kita und
das macht jetzt mit den anderen beiden
auch kurze unterbrechung mir ist
aufgefallen dass das ein bisschen breit
ist und jetzt habe ich das mal so zu
kleinen schnecken geformt also so
gerollt und jetzt sieht das irgendwie
doch ein bisschen ansprechende aus also
mache ich so weiter unsere flächen sind
nicht fertig und die kommen jetzt nur
unter strom
wir müssen jetzt uns dreimal den zopf so
rüber packen die hälfte ein richtiger
sammlung reich sind verstehen aus so
dass ich den film schauen will lade ich
mir einfach leute ein und werden dieses
ding backen das ist doch richtig geil
das sind die die aus ihrem film und so
schnell ist er eigentlich gemacht ich
werde ihn jetzt in den ofen ton bei 150
grad ungefähr für 25 bis 30 minuten also
dass er schön goldbraun ist und man das
gefühl hat jetzt kann der raum und jetzt
kommt das schöne dinge in den ofen
und während das dinge zum guten ist
versuchen wir die rosen zu basteln aus
der apfel schale von den äpfeln sollten
wir das doch jetzt hinkriegen oder nimmt
die apf schale und drehten so nach innen
ein was gar nicht mehr so schwer wirkt
so ich meine es ist keine schöne rose
aber man sieht auf jeden fall was es
sein soll und jetzt es geht einfacher
als gibt nicht so bleiben wollen raus
schülerströme ist bereit
toto ihr seht ihr gar nicht er muss
jetzt auf jeden fall noch ganz lange
abkühlen und wenn er dann abgekühlt ist
werden wir ihn dekorieren und dann
probieren
bis gleich nur noch mit unseren rosen
dekorieren und mein gott sieht das schon
aus
[Musik]
bei meinem rosen sieht man so ganz
kleiner heute schließen weil ich manche
befestigen musst du weißt ja aber nicht
fest gekriegt haben er sieht so kraft
aus wie der aus dem film jetzt kommt
noch eine ordentliche portion
puderzucker um drauf
[Musik]
okay leute ich würde mal sagen ney wird
der sieht wirklich einfach aus wie der
aus dem fan und jetzt stehen uns
natürlich wieder der allerwichtigsten
frage wie schmeckt der apfelstrudel den
kini backt für news gemander und
kowalski aus fantastische thesen und wo
sie zu finden sind
ich bin so unglaublich stolz sie könnte
sogar ich bin ist so super stolz
guten appetit leute ist so knusprig
etwas was so gut aussieht kann ja nur
gut schmeckt man muss dazu auf jeden
fall noch ein glas verkauf von ihr
nichts im weg stehen kriegen die nehme
ich noch ein becher kakao
ich weiß nicht ob ich jemals etwas so
schönes gemacht habe - bricht er auch
schon wieder ist so zerfällt und diese
drei schichten sind gar nicht zu viel
und so schwer war jetzt auch gar nicht
man muss ein bisschen blättert einkaufen
äpfel gut die rosen das ist eine schöne
arbeit aber ansonsten das ist ein
richtig cooles bisher oder zum zweiten
teil wenn man den zweiten teil
vielleicht anschauen will dann kann man
ja so ein abend machen wo man dann das
macht oder den ersten teil auf sky also
wenn ich euch jetzt lust auf diesen film
gemacht habe oder auf andere filme wie
zum beispiel skull island oder ich
einfach unverbesserlich 3 dann schaut
mal unten in den ersten link da kommt
die zudem sky angebot 999 für zwei
monate cinema ticket ich finde es ist
ein gutes angebot es gibt eine große
filmauswahl ich bin auf jeden fall echt
begeistert gewesen als das gesehen habe
ich bin ein bisschen aus atem
das kommt von der freude es kommt von
der freude und das war es aber auch
schon mit dieser folge wie schmeckt ich
hoffe euch hat es gefallen wenn jahren
hinterlässt mit dem daumen nach oben
schreibt ein nettes kommentar oder einen
vorschlag was sich vielleicht noch
kochen soll ausfüllen oder serien habt
ihr ideen ab damit in die kommentare
hier findet ihr noch weitere videos und
ansonsten abonniert main kanal und
aktiviert die glocke wenn ihr wirklich
meine videos mit bekommen wollt dann
aktiviert diese glocke weil irgendwie
spinnt youtube in letzter zeit kommt ich
bin ziemlich glücklich und ich dieses
kennt ihr das wenn etwas gemacht hat was
sehr viel zeit in anspruch genommen hat
und so wie ihr euch so wirklich drauf
gefreut hat und damit lässt sich so gut
ich fühle mich jetzt da rein legen als
so lecker ist